to try and make sense of what is going
on here we're going to add a fifth
equation to business to four okay but
before I do that I just want to give you
an analogy for what we're observing here
or experiencing okay in the nineteenth
century
eighteen eighty twenty something okay
there was a botanist what was that's
like flowers and that couldn't be maybe
there's a botanist his name is Robert
Brown and he was looking down the lens
of his microscope okay he was examining
some pollen that was suspended in some
water okay now what happened was he
looked at the pollen that it was
underneath the microscope and as he
looked at the pollen which was sitting
underneath the lens of the microscope
perfectly still all the waters settled
nothing was moving here is something
weird he noticed that the bits of pollen
they were kind of like bobbing around
they were sort of she doing in this
unusual way they weren't perfectly still
and that was unusual because like if you
look at the the slide nothing is moving
around but I really want you zoom in you
see these things just kind of being
pushed around as if there was something
invisible invisible particles that were
sort of like nudging the bits of pollen
here then now Brown couldn't see what
was going on but he took a record of
that he said it's a bit weird
interesting right now what you've got
here is the same kind of idea there are
roots here that can be apparently added
and multiplied together but I can't see
where this root are like where are they
they they don't exist down here okay and
in the same way
Brown noticed well these things are
moving there are some like visible
effects but I can't see the thing I
can't see the thing that's making those
effects happen okay
so to see that to give us a new set of
glasses to actually interpret what's
going on the fifth equation we're gonna
add is this I'm gonna put it yeah
here's the fifth equation okay now I
want you to notice I'm still using
natural numbers well two one and zero to
build this thing I'm still using very
straightforward operations plus minus
times divide multiplication doing it a
couple of times it's just what gives me
that index up there but notice what
happens as we go ahead and solve this
right I'm gonna do the same thing with
this that you probably did with with
this guy over here I'm gonna subtract
one from both sides like that now at
this point right you would have said x
squared plus x squared equals five and
then you would have taken the square
root of both sides right so I'm gonna do
exactly the same thing here right X is
going to be equal to plus or minus the
square root over here was fine over here
I have a negative one on the right hand
side so I have a negative one here now
ordinarily we would say what that
doesn't exist and you would just say
there are no solutions and you return
okay but actually it's not that there
are no solutions it's that there are no
real solutions there are no solutions
through this that fit all of these
patterns just like and when you move
from here to here or here to here every
time you go down an equation you can see
the solution to these equations they
kind of break the rules of these
pre-established we call B sense right of
these pre-established sets of numbers
you know you look at this guy he's
rational it's like well you can't
express the rational number in the
National numbers although all the
integers write in the same way this
thing this thing is different to what
you've been seeing before okay so she is
different we're going to introduce some
new notation we're going to say this is
the square root of a negative number
particularly the square root of negative
one we're going to name it I the I
stands for imaginary which is an
unfortunate name because these numbers
are imaginary they exist just as much as
all the other numbers do but we're just
going to use that as a label so we're
going to say it's possible and I where I
we define that as the square
now this thing here is going to help us
to work out like what's what on earth is
going on here okay but before we do that
we've introduced a huge new idea so we
need to lay some foundations this is not
just a new idea it's a new kind of
number that's different to all these
other numbers that you've observed for
before so we need to lay some
foundations in fact that's a little
something I'd like to make foundations
what I'm gonna do is I need you to
understand a little bit better what
these real numbers are before we can
contrast them with these okay
now that's hard to do to find real
numbers and have a good definition for
those because we all known as the other
kinds of numbers you've ever known it's
a bit like asking a fish can you
describe water for me it's like well
it's everything is water
okay well everything you've dealt with
the field numbers before so therefore
I'm going to give you two formal
definitions for this right to help you
that way going in to look at and we're
gonna return this definition these
definitions a couple of times because
what we're doing with complex numbers
are very much a contrast of these okay
so here's my first definition for a real
number right a real number is any number
you can express as a single decimal
expansion any number you can express in
a single decimal expansion come back
over here for a second when you have a
look at these guys right I said I sort
of mentioned on the side the rational
numbers they're the decimals that are
either turning decimals like 0.5 a 0 / 2
5 or the recurring decimal was like zero
point 3 3 3 2 3 3 3 3 3 etc okay all the
rational numbers can be expressed in
that way the irrational numbers all of
the decimals that they they keep on
going and they never terminate they know
curr okay they're not repeating decimals
is what we call them but in the same way
they're all in this family of real
numbers so I can write them as a single
decimal expansion so that's what a real
number is we have a another name for
this by the way that will come back to a
couple of weeks we call that a scaler
okay a single decimal expansion it's not
the early definition though when you
first started dealing with numbers
particularly with integers right
do you remember to help you work out
like there's positive numbers and then
there's negative numbers and they have a
direction in fact integers earlier on
you might have heard the court directed
numbers to help you understand that we
drew this thing right does anyone
remember like this thing is called the
number line right the number line
yeah the great thing about all of the
real numbers what every single one of
them shares in common is that you can
find a place on this number line for
every single real number that exists
every single real number you can pick
off you can find a place on the line
right so therefore the formal definition
that goes with that is that a real
number is a value that represents a
point on a line and it can be a point to
the right of zero or to the left is here
it's positive or negative right so any
value that represents the point on a
wife okay but as you will see if you
allow for the square roots of negative
numbers these numbers don't behave like
this you can't write them as single
decimal expansions and you can't
visualize them just with a line you need
something else as well okay and we'll
come back to that in a minute what I
want to do now that we have our
definitions it's just down to lately
some foundations in terms of how would
work with these numbers okay so we call
I the square root negative 1 we called
this the imaginary unit and the reason
why is because you can stay every
imaginary number as some multiple of
this imaginary unit watch this okay so
for example the square root of negative
25 okay
a squared negative 25 we usually say you
can't value it but if we have the
as an idea there's nothing that stops us
working with this do you agree that
underneath that square root they get 25
I can write that as negative started 25
times negative 1 dude agree with that
it's just the product after all now one
of the things that you do a lot with
irrational numbers with Serbs when you
first learn about them is you simplify
them by taking advantage of a rule here
right like if I gave you the square root
of say 20 ok we know we can simplify
this because we're going to do the same
thing that I just did right the thing I
donate there's a product right and then
say hey look this is a square number so
I could pull it out right I can write
this as root 4 root 5 yes so we're
familiar with this and that's why we
would say oh yeah - root 5 that's
simpler than root 20 well I could be
just the same thing here right I can
write this as root 25 root negative 1 do
you agree I'm just I'm just split into
two just like I split that into two so
the respiratory 5 is 5 and I have just
given a name to this root negative 1 I
just called it like that's all and any
imaginary number this is another
imaginary part it's just a multiple of I
this is a real number this is an
imaginary number so it's a real multiple
of the imaginary unit and they just have
to work with like nice detail is like 25
if I said the square root of negative 3
I just do the same thing this is the
square root of 3 times negative 1 I'll
break that into two pieces and you read
3 I can't do anything with that's okay
I'll just leave it there but this guy
I'm just right is alright ok no big deal